[Music]
driver
chesses history and that player is
Emmanuel Lasker now there's been someone
watching the lectures for like a month
now who every lecture he posts an emoji
of the prayer hints and says please let
this lecture be about Lasker and this
time it finally is but by some strange
twist of fate I don't see him in the
chat tonight so he might miss it
disaster
that being said Emanuel a skirt was by
far the strongest player in the world
for a period of time and I had a
conversation with Dennis Boros earlier
today and last group may have been the
first chess player to play chess at the
super high level that we are more
accustomed to today the way he phrased
it was Lasker's it's kind of the first
2700 level player in his opinion and
that was an opinion I shared so why
don't we see how Lasker took down some
of his contemporaries with his strong
play uh and chess bobble is here the guy
who wanted the Lasker lectures and you
your time is now buddy all right
efore 'if I've Lasker you know an e4
player himself responds with the best
move e5 just challenging the center now
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5
we have the Italian and then everybody's
favorite opening opening line in the
Italian the Evans gambit was chigorin's
choice in this particular game and of
course the Evans gambit is not the most
well respected opening these days it
gives up this be pawn for some quick
play in the center but it's generally
not gonna be enough for white to get
full compensation for the pawn okay I
don't know what that was but
we powered through all right before
Bishop takes b4 is the free pawn c3 now
is the point and this Bishop drops back
to c5 not a five in this game a little
bit of a sideline by Alaska and now
rather than d4 immediately white went
ahead and castled black responded with
d6 here and now after d4 the bishop just
drops back to be six so now white in
exchange for the b-pawn has gotten this
nice solid structure up in the center
and gain and a couple Tempe against this
bishop that had to go out to be four now
there are a few things white can do here
in the game white shows not to touch
this central configuration and instead
played the move a4 perhaps looking at a
later date to play a move like Bishop a3
get on this long diagonal it also hints
at some a five threats if this night
ever for example had to leave then of
course a five would would trap this
Bishop so in the game Alaska simply
develops his pieces with Knight to f6
and now Bishop b5 was Mahale chigorin's
choice
so Bishop b5 of course makes a threat
however it isn't actually the greatest
move in the position for white to start
getting some compensation he needs to
open up the position kind of immediately
with a move like D takes e5 and after D
takes d5 even just to move like Queen e2
and now Bishop a3 for example is
attempting to stop black from castling
and if black castles immediately on the
bishop a through anyways in Africa Gate
rook d1 white is gaining some Tempe and
has his pieces on nice active active
squares so okay instead of D takes e5
though Bishop e5 and now Lasker simply
plays a6 and giving his Bishop of flight
Square and attacking this Bishop Bishop
takes c6 b takes c6 a5 comes on the
board anyways this Bishop drops back to
a7 and now we do in fact see white
capture on e5 so now at first glance
this does look rather awkward for lat
Dilys of course recapturing would be a
pretty big mistake due to the fact that
this epon is simply hanging and there
are some awkward threats for black to
deal with but last year it comes up with
a pretty good move here
he simply takes on e4 ignoring this 'if
I've pawn and regaining his pawn on the
other square now if white isn't careful
here black is simply going to play the
move d5 and stabilize in the center so
what black or what white would love to
do is play the movie takes d6
but unfortunately black has a really
nice move in response to this so can you
guys at home find the only way to
maintain an advantage or the best way to
maintain an advantage with black in this
position hopefully you can you can find
it here and also I'm told by Ben that we
are streaming with low latency tonight
so maybe just maybe I will stick around
and wait for you guys to answer and yet
janek already has an answer
you just Castle here you don't need to
get bogged down playing things like
Queen takes d6 when after Queen e2
things are just gonna get awkward for
you trying to defend this night instead
also notably if C takes D 6 then things
like Queen a4 also are attacking many
things at the same time so instead
simply castles and if white wants to
gain the pawn back with D takes e7 he's
more than welcome to black can simply
recapture this or even take on d1 and
take on f2 and black is gonna be better
so rather than that we see the move
Queen e2 a little bit more of
[Music]
a closed position now rather than the
ones we were looking at white keeps the
tension with the pawn on e5
so rather than things simplifying so
quickly into just a better position for
black Chu Goran tries to keep pieces on
the board with Queen e2 and it goes for
some more complications of course after
Queen e2 though black has a very nice
opportunity to close things up in the
center and it's exactly what he does
just place the move d5 and Lasker has
has really made it look look easy here
he just played very very natural moves
and now on move 13 he stands
significantly better with a powerful
Knight in the center powerful bishop on
a7 plenty of space for this Bishop to
develop and safety for his King so this
and this one has already very much gone
his way in the game White tried Knight
d4 and I don't know why that keeps
happening oh my goodness okay in the
game white tried Knight d4 which of
course is simply going to be a pretty
significant blunder here
Lasker takes this opportunity to win a
second pawn with the move Knight takes
c3 just removing the defender of this
Knight hitting the Queen so there's no
time for Knight takes c6 Knight takes c3
was played in the game and now Bishop
takes d4 hitting two things at the same
time Queen d3 but of course black cannot
really capture this because of the open
e file so now c5 and this is the problem
with gambits like these if your opponent
can use the extra pawn as a piece to
control squares then is just going to
stand positionally better as well as
materially better the problem with a lot
of gambits isn't so much that you're
just down upon you know people seem to
think like being down a pawn is like
something that'll affect you later in
the game right you're down upon but at
least you have a good position but
sometimes that pawn itself is a very
useful piece and ends up very much
improving your
position so c5 and now these ponds that
are extra for black are controlling
squares that white is simply helpless to
challenge with all of these three pawns
missing from the board okay in the game
though Queen g3 was played Bishop e6 is
blacks response now if you do take on g7
here perhaps Alaska's idea was to play
the move King d7 when all of a sudden
this Knight is attacked and rook g8 is
threatened if you play the move Queen g3
rook G it anyways Queen f3 Queen h4 and
my how the tables have turned suddenly
it is black who is going for a
devastating King side attack with
pressure on the Queen side as well so
rather than Queen g7 Bishop g5
westergaard's choice and now Queen d7 be
really great that stopped happening okay
rook a c1 and now alas Kurt makes a
little bit of a misstep here he was
worried about castling because if you do
castle here moves like Bishop f6 or even
Bishop h6 could potentially be very
serious threats for example Bishop f6
it's not so easy so just play a move
like g6 because you can very quickly end
up checkmated here so to solve this
problem perhaps the best move was
actually just to play aged six to drive
this bishop away now Bishop f4 you can
take on c3 take on c3 and even expand
with moves like g5 if you like it was
like c4 and black is sitting perfectly
fine instead Lasker 24 a slightly
simpler approach in order to guard the
dark squares on the Kings side he wanted
this bishop to be able to come back to
help so he played the move f6 which of
course been find gold fans are going to
be very upset about the idea being now
this bishop can kind of access this
Kings side help defend a couple squares
unfortunately though now with this EEP
on out of the way
after takes and takes Bishop f4 the open
e file serves to her help white more
than it helps black with the
defense of the bishop now rook g8 though
Queen f3 and Queen side castles last
skirt brings his King to the Queen side
and well f6 may have not been the most
accurate way to continue he is still
just completely completely better here
in fact probably just a simple win for
black at this point we're Kathy one was
how jus Goran chose to continue and now
after c4 Queen e2 Bishop f5 it's looking
like these pawns are just going to roll
but after Queen a2 Lasker played a
pretty good move here which I would like
you guys at home to try your best and
find see if you can find the way to
really kind of put white out of his
misery here you know if you play some
other move yes you're still just gonna
be totally winning what is happening
okay I don't know how my laptop is it's
going a bit a bit haywire here but okay
if you don't find the best move here you
are still going to be winning but it's
just going to take you some time to push
these funds and you always run a little
bit of a risk of having a slightly
unsafe King with this open bead file but
yes see if you guys at home can find the
tactic okay everybody wants to take on
g2 but who seems to follow up who sees
follow up how do you check mates after
rook takes g2 how do you check me
this is very annoying I don't know I'm
pressing all the keys we're gonna get
there all right
hopefully my random keep pressing has
has helps okay everybody seems to have
the answer
hello to Dave Terre as well rook takes G
to King takes G to Bishop h3 check is in
fact going to be mate if King edge one
just queen g4 and there's no way to stop
Queen f3 and Queen G to wreck g1 for
example is not enough just check me and
this is probably why the Queen should
not go all the way over to a2 but of
course by this point Lasker already had
a pretty winning position here in the
game King each one was played and after
rook takes f2 chigorin had had enough
and resigned in this game so where did
it all go wrong for Jordan well some
people might argue that it all went
wrong for Juke Oren when he played them
with B for it but here his position
should be fine D for Bishop e6 and I
think where it really did start to go
kind of south was this a-four a-five
idea it just wasted a lot of time in an
opening where White has sacrificed an
entire pawn for that extra time and a4
a5 just isn't really the way to use it
so after this series of moves I really
do think that black is just strictly
better here takes takes and Queen e2
also just allows black to stabilize in
the center with a healthy extra pawn and
targets on c3 somehow Lasker just got it
all this game and then finished it off
with a nice tactic
b4 is a very good move since Akash I
know some players who might disagree but
ok let's take a look at another game of
Lasker's now we have Lasker up against
the one and only Frank James Marshall of
course of Marshall gambit Fame and so
Lasker just to talk a little bit about
his openings I was researching a few of
his games going into tonight's lecture
and he seems to just exclusively play
the movie for you know he seems to be a
purist so the rest of the games tonight
are going to be Lasker playing this
movie for and just crushing his
opponents honestly the guy it was
impressive so the movie 4 and E 5 was
Marshalls reply now after Knight f3
Marshall did not go for the Royal
opposed instead playing Knight f6 when
we are in the Petroff d6 Knight back to
f3 Knight takes e4 and then Lasker shows
a very dross line actually played the
move Queen e2 Queen e2 of course pins
the knight to the king only way to save
this piece is to block in kind with
Queen e7 and now after d3 Knight f6
Bishop g5 pretty much exclusively today
players end up taking on e to Trading
the Queen's going into a very equal ish
endgame in this game though Marshall
plays the move Bishop e6 and now it is
kind of a much different story the game
is not going to be the boorish the
boring jarash endgame and that's we were
expecting instead with Queens on the
board it can turn quite exciting as it
did in this case
so Knight c3 followed known IP d7 Queen
side castles for whites h6 by black
Bishop h4 and g5 and here
Black is just gaining some Kings side
space because he already knows he's
likely going to tuck this King over on
the Queen side so h6 g5 forces this
Bishop back to g3 and then Marshall goes
for Knight h5 trying to take this Bishop
off the board before it ever gets active
d4 is White's reply and this is a pretty
nice move because it's giving the white
pieces access to the queenside
it's also stopping the moves 95 and 95
for the moment sometimes it is really
just good to take central space okay now
you take g3 though is played h6 g3 and
now after g4 this night is looking
slightly awkward here on f3 lasker it
simply brings it over to the h4 square
and now white continues with the move d5
so on the surface this position doesn't
look like it's about to explode or
anything it looks you know fairly normal
I would say black has the bishop pair
and white has a slightly sidelined
Knights but you know there's there's an
open e file and a lot of times in
positions like these you know there will
be a few slow moves for example like
Queen t2 castles Bishop d3 just getting
developed let's say Bishop g7 even you
know Ricky one
okay well I'm playing very badly now but
let's say like Bishop a5 or something
fending this pawn
eventually pieces are going to come to
the e-file and a lot of pieces are just
gonna get traded off and at the end of
the day it's it's gonna be yet another
boring draw but Lasker found a really
nice move here to immediately put some
pressure on his opponents and his
opponent didn't really respond in the
best way so let's see if you can find a
two to three move plan for Falasca here
that is really just a series of very
forcing moves so a series of forcing
moves for Alaska that can generate a
nice advantage or even attack in this
position see if you guys can find it
see what you can find I get the feeling
some of you may know this game
everybody just immediately suggests and
the best moves okay I'll talk about the
incorrect moves first Queen e5 seems bad
because the Knight takes e5 is illegal
move but yeah the move f4 doesn't really
strike me as the best here you're going
for this f5 idea I guess but the problem
is you're always going to have to be
worried about this check on g5 so f5 is
actually not quite so simple to achieve
I think I can just ignore it
queenside castle and after f5 this guy
is going to drop off the board so maybe
not f4 here it's true that white would
like to see this exchange come off the
board fixing the pawn structure a little
bit but the problem is I don't think you
can you can force black to go for this
okay
f3 has a similar idea trying to get
black to take here but once again black
is just going to ignore and doubled
pawns might not always be bad but triple
pawns are pretty terrible pretty
terrible stuff so the move of course is
in fact going to be Queen to b5 and then
only one person really found the two to
three move idea that I was asking for
everybody else just kind of stopped at
Queen b5 or 95 which I guess I should
talk about Knight b5 once again just
Queen side castles if you actually take
this guy
well King b8 denied b5 and black is
finding some counter play here with
between g5 check c6 and Bishop d6 just
getting developed other responses
tonight b5 if you want to be a little
bit simpler but I can actually get away
with playing a move like King d8 here
the reason being after white makes some
move we're gonna have the move c6 king
c7 and we are getting to safety like
this kind of castling by hand for black
keeping all of the material queen b5
instead though and this is really going
to be the
the devastating move for Lasker queen
bee five Queen side castles and now
Queen a5 is the point and so the easy
line to solve is what happens on King b8
this is the easy one hopefully you guys
at home I'll see the idea for white
after King b8 of course the idea is
going to be to play Knight to b5 and
this is as simple of a fork as it really
gets and this is just wrecking the the
black King site and black is of course
going to be lost after either Knight
takes 4 or Queen takes but okay instead
of King b8 a6 is a much harder try so
now the question is is the move Bishop
takes a6 worth it or not
this is kind of the natural end to the
line we've been following but we need to
decide if we have enough after Bishop
takes a 6-2 in fact win this game so try
and find try and find the continuation
after the sacrifice you know it's easy
to say yeah we should sacrifice and then
and then go for it but you need to find
a nice continuation that really shows
the idea here
so ours Malaya says yes but no
continuation so I will remain here
momentarily
then Nye b5 but the game doesn't end
with 95
the game doesn't end with nigh b5 that B
5 is not checkmate you can't really end
end there does black have a defense
after Knight b5
try and treat this kind of thing like a
real chess game for those of you who
watch the video replay of these lectures
especially for you guys if you just
pause the video when I start to ask
these questions I really encourage you
guys to take some time try and think it
through to the end of the variation
calculating complete variations is a
huge part of chess and you can't really
just end with 95 and it looks good
that's it's not good enough 95 is not
checkmate perpetual check I I mean I
don't see a perpetual check there either
you just you're just saying words my god
9 a 4 to put the knight on c5 so okay so
Kobe doesn't want to take on a 6
okay everybody in the chat ends their
line with the move Knight to b5 and
something simple is just giving me the
top engine line which is a bit silly
just a bit silly
so rook d3 is the key after Knight b5 so
that is as close I think as I'm going to
get so of course the sacrifice is going
to be strong here now if your name is
something simple and you're reading the
engine output it will tell you to play C
6 and then Bishop b2 and then Queen B 4
and then takes and then takes but that's
I'm not looking for the engine output
guys I want you guys to use your brain
so of course in a practical game when
you lose this pawn on a6 you're going to
recapture the bishop here or else you're
kind of just admitting that's that
you're going to be just dead lost
basically significantly worse so now at
least you're forcing your opponent to to
prove something Queen takes a6 King be
895 was where you guys all ended your
lines but after the move Knight b6 it
really isn't quite so simple here for
white in fact there's really only one
winning move so a few of you did
actually managed to come up with me here
but if I can critique perhaps you guys a
little bit more you can't end your
calculations after the move rook d3 if
you guys find yourself in a tournament
game and you're trying to calculate
sacrifices like these you must must must
calculate further than then the move
rook d3 it's pretty easy to actually get
this far in your head if if you really
sit down buckle down and try to
calculate right so Bishop takes a6 you
know B takes a6 can kind of just be
assumed now this move is checked there's
one legal move
and this move threatens check and mate
there's only one reasonable way to stop
it here for black you have to play
Knight b6 and now all of these were only
moves and so you can begin the
calculation at rook d3 rather than then
end it there
so rook d3 and we can begin our
calculations here now I understand this
is just a video lecture and thinking is
hard and annoying but if you guys want
to get the most from these then you
really do have to try and work that
calculation muscle and think about these
things but okay rook d3 was of course
played in the game in this
is the correct response now the Queen g5
is a Czech king b1 and Bishop d6 was
marshals try to defend the position
unfortunately now it is quite simply
just losing so who sees the winning plan
to get rid of the last defenders around
this black King how can we get rid of
the final defenders around the king
night a seven is a pretty good move here
might actually just be a winning move
not the idea I had in mind though night
a seven going for a knight c6 does look
pretty good pretty good
not gonna lie but after Bishop d7 you
have to come up with with I think the
original idea anyways Knight takes D six
has been suggested Knight takes c6 isn't
going to be my favorite move here
trading one attacker for one defender is
sometimes a really useful idea when you
have kind of an abundance of attackers
but in this case you really only have
these three attackers and by giving away
the night the rook actually comes into
play and is is also serving as a good
defender of the King so 90 x d6 isn't
gonna be it maybe perhaps we need bigger
attack or more attackers
how can we bring in even more attackers
to the game
okay a b c d e f g a g h i j k l m seems
to be forgetting that after Knight takes
c6 you no longer have an item b5 so
Quincy 7 is not checkmate
okay now everybody wants to bring in the
rook so okay we'll start with bringing
in the rook and in the game Rick 88 was
played in response but now now do we
have enough attackers to find a forcing
win or do we need even more
wink-wink do we need even more do we
need even more rook a3 was also a pretty
reasonable move that rook isn't actually
adding much to the a file we still can't
really go Queen a8 and Queen a7 is
possible with this Knight here anyways
alright everybody does seem to have the
move now of course we need to get rid of
the defender around the king that is the
night I was looking for ways to get rid
of this night so you all wanted to
remove the bishop but that actually
wasn't going to be enough in these
positions just Rick takes d6 and I think
black is actually just winning now
because you know black has more pieces
so if he doesn't get checkmated things
are gonna go his way now if you even
play move like rook III Queen d2 in
everything around this the center in the
the Queen side for white is starting to
fall so we definitely need this night as
an attacker some of rook b3 is fine to
start with but also the original idea
1/4 works in this position as well you
didn't need to play rugby 3 first it is
fine to player it could be 3 first and
after a 8 a 4 is what last your place
and now it is just over after Bishop f5
white does actually bring in this Knight
a7 idea but Bishop d7 like I said is
enough to stop
see six and now a five the initial plan
is what Marshall goes with to play for
checkmate I also don't know if you guys
can hear all these noises going on
around me it's it's pretty scary they're
doing some work above us I think doing
some work on the floor above us so yeah
a 485 is the last key idea to win the
game Queen d2 and after a couple checks
this game is over 95 a great move for
Lasker and now Queen a7 and marshal
resigns of course b7 and b8 is difficult
to stop in fact there's even a faster
mate more beautiful more beautiful
faster mate a perfect and checkmate as
they say so another great game from
Alaska here
the key point being this Queen b5 move
you have to calculate to the end of
these variations and Lasker was a very
accurate very talented calculator from
my experience in looking at these games
it's difficult to just kind of assess
positions after sacrifices like those
because one wrong move in the evaluation
very much can a change in blacks favor
as we saw with the move Knight takes t6
but in this case hopefully you guys
calculate to the end of the lines in
your own games and see that after rook
d3 you do have this winning plan of a4
and a5 that is the key idea to see so if
you want to treat these positions like a
calculation puzzle after the move a 6
when you're deciding if you can
sacrifice Bishop takes a6 or not you
should already be trying to find these
ideas like a4 a5 to follow because like
I said these are all pretty much only
moves for black up until the move rook
d3 so hopefully this was a little bit
instructive this game the story as
always with chess is about calculating
calculating plays a huge role in all of
these games
okay let's jump to the next game by
Lasker here I've got this one between
Alaska and another chess historical last
legend
Hosea Raul capablanca so Capablanca of
course is a world-famous player probably
even more famous than Alaska and he's
known for his stunning positional play
however I don't think this is a game
that makes it into one of Kappa Blancas
greatest because Lasker actually quite
simply just out plays kappa blanka on
the position here so let's see how he
does it like I said last Kurt a tried
and true efore player so II 6 d4 d5 he
goes for the win a war with Knight c3
Bishop b4 and now rather than go for the
main stuff with moves like a five and a
three Alaska it plays a slightly less
common move still pretty standard the
move 92 and rather than get those close
to type of window are positions where
White is trying to do things on the
Kings side black is pushing on the Queen
side we get a more open game with D
takes e4 being black's main move and
after G takes c4 things in the center
open up a little bit and it becomes more
about piece play than these plans on
either side of the board a3 comes on the
board Bishop back to e7 and now Knight
takes e4 regains the pawn Knight f6 by
Black Knight to c3 is getting the white
pieces in the game Knight bTW 7 is
black's choice Bishop f4 both sides just
continued development and black takes
off one set of Knights brings the other
Knight to f6 and now Bishop d3 is
Laskaris choice just very very natural
development so far by both the sides
black went ahead and got Castle here and
now white plays the move Knight takes f6
taking off
night perhaps actually the move castles
was kind of the beginning of the end for
Capablanca really the the movement needs
to be played here is a move that gets
this Bishop into the game some moves
like Bishop d7 start to become pretty
relevant here I think it's absolutely
critical for black to get this Bishop
into the game as soon as possible or
else he really risks exactly what
happened in the game and that is this
Bishop got trapped behind its own pawns
and was unable to really contribute so
castles we see takes on f6 takes on f6
now with pressure on the d4 pawn Lasker
stunts this bishop and this Queen with
the move c3 and now I've kind of hinted
to you guys that the main problem for
black is the bishop on c8 but I'd like
to ask you guys what should black be
trying to do to solve this problem how
can black try to free the pieces in this
position what can you try to do here
Bishop d7 is one thought Bishop g7 not a
bad idea at all
oh and sorry yeah I neglected to mention
the deep on was never hanging due to a
simple discovered discovered check
tactic so there are a few ideas roaming
around the chat the main contenders seem
to be Bishop d7 to c6 the move b6 the
move e5 and these are the main ideas and
then yes also included is the move
c5 so a lot of you are on the right
track here the problem for black yes is
this Bishop but it's also the fact that
it's just down this comfortable central
space with this pawn on d4 look at all
natural the white pieces are with this
pawn working with them so in order to
ever truly be equal in this position
black is going to need to do something
about this deep on and that means
playing for the breaks
b5 or c5 and judging by this game that's
where we really start to see why
capablanca is in significant trouble
here for one the move e5 is just quite
difficult to achieve
you play the move rook e8 trying to get
you five white can simply castle and if
you go for it now well simply takes
takes takes and tactically you really
cannot go for this do two more
discovered checks so II five immediately
not going to be playable so capablanca
likely notice this tactic otherwise rook
e8 would be a very very natural move
here and so he played the move Queen d5
instead now I challenge you guys at home
to try and find the best move for white
here the move that Laster played is very
instructive and very intuitive actually
how did he play against Queen d5
keeping in mind blacks ideas of playing
for a break here
something simple wants to simply Castle
kingside
so castling kingside definitely isn't a
bad idea here but I do think it slightly
gives black what he wants the move Queen
c2 is also suggested this does make a
threat so black would have to respond
with g6 and then you can kind of go
about your next move
but the move I was looking for is the
move played in the game it's the move
Queen e2 you just keep an eye on this e5
square quite closely not allowing black
to break through if you do castle
perhaps maybe black could get away with
playing as c5 rather than a five if I've
immediately of course still doesn't work
due to these tactics but yet c5 also
rook t8 is likely blacks idea with E 5
to follow so yeah after Queen e2 though
the move c5 is going to be a little bit
less appealing for black and the
reasoning is well now we have this nice
move Bishop b4 and so with Queen e2
Lasker is looking to prevent both of
blacks mainframe moves and that's why
you know I am kind of looking at this
game as lasker just positionally out
playing kappa blanka if you ever find
yourself in a position like this with
black against a structure like this for
white you really do have to get one of
these breaks and breaks in or else you
were just going to be quite simply it
worse and Queen e2 is the move that best
highlights that fact now of course the
move Queen takes g2 is you know
potentially possible for black here
white would just either Castle queenside
insert Bishop e4 first maybe and then
just go on the attack here on the G file
and and this is also going to be very
uncomfortable for black notably still
not able to break in the center with c5
or a 5s so Queen e2 is the stellar move
that's that Lasker came up with in the
game now you all wanted a couple other
ways to activate the bishops so c5 and E
5 you kind of call that plan a and B
right you want to break down this
central pawn on d4 and get your pieces
into the game but now we're really at
the point where we need some back
plants and so because of that I think
black really should have considered
playing the move Bishop d7 here the
reason he didn't is because it does hang
this c7 pawn but after a move like rook
c8 push it back to g3 well whack is
going to get some activity over here
with this Bishop coming out and there's
still always this pawn hanging here on
on g2 that White has to be slightly
concerned with so I do think this idea
of bringing this Bishop out in this way
would have been nice here for last or
for kappa blanka in fact maybe you could
even consider doing it instead of
playing this move Queen d5 now black or
white would probably simply castle maybe
Bishop out to c6 and this Bishop at
least is breathing a little bit even if
the black position isn't the most
comfortable with this pawn stuck on c7
with the way things went in the game
though kappa blanka went for this move
c6 and this is starting to get real bad
because now of course you can never get
the bishop out on this diagonal we can
never get the bishop out on this
diagonal and that bishop is it's just a
dead piece and now white goes on to play
a very nice game where it's it's really
almost as if he's just up a full Bishop
here and I really spent a lot of time on
these moves like 9 through 13 and the
reason for that is I wanted to make sure
you guys understand how Lasker got such
a crushing position here it's not
because josé raúl capablanca was playing
terrible terrible chess it's that he
recognized the important breaks for
black and moves c5 and E 5 and he found
the best way to make sure those never
happen so this kind of play this
restrictive play is stuff that you
really see from strong players today and
that's why I really think Lasker was
very very impressive for his time this
ability to recognize the opponent's plan
even if it's slightly subtle and be able
to find all these nuanced ways to
prevent it from happening is really
killer stuff from Lasker so Queen e2 a
great move by Lasker and now he's simply
castles in his
intent to sit with his much better
position if you ask some computers these
days they want to just kind of like go
go kill black immediately but I mean
castles is a comfortable advantage for
white rook e8 now comes on the board and
of course with E 5 coming
Lasker finds more ways to prevent it
rook e1 was definitely playable Bishop
e5 is also worth considering but he
chose the move rook a to d1 challenging
the Queen on the D file and he's
preventing a5 in this manner of course
now if you five once again we're going
to take and these pesky discovered
checks are going to be black's downfall
once again so Bishop d7 instead but of
course the d7 square hardly improves
this Bishop and Lasker just continues
here rook to e1 and now with all of the
pieces coming into play kappa blanka is
just kind of a sitting duck in this
position
why not Queen's Queen takes g2 we talked
about that briefly Queen takes g2 was a
playable move in this position but of
course black or white is just going to
look for some counter play along this G
file and in fact after move like Bishop
e4 and Bishop takes c7 it's not really
even a pawn sacrifice as white is
regaining this pawn immediately I kind
of prefer the line though where it is a
pawn sacrifice with Queen side castles
and just going after this King directly
this is totally good fine fine for white
and even better than fine I think White
has a a nice advantage here with this
compensation but instead just c6 and now
castles defends the pawn okay so Ricky a
trick d1 Bishop d7 urkki 1 and now kappa
blanka plays queen a5 which really feels
like a nothing move but the the
difficult part of this position is you
know it's it's really tough to play a
something move here so Kevin Lanka just
removes the Queen from this file
opposite the rook in order to really
desperately try it to get one of these
breaks in now Lasker kind of switches
gears here place the move Queen c2
hitting this pawn on h7 and now after g6
I challenge you once again to make sure
black does not get the breaks that he
wants make sure black cannot break free
yeah everybody seems to have it of
course the move here is Bishop e5 you
stop the move e5 and you challenge since
Bishop and if Bishop takes e5 rook takes
e5 now you're regarding these scores
forever
and this guy is still the worst so
Bishop e5 Bishop g7 was played in the
game and now one last question for you
guys here find the plan to continue the
attack on the Kings side White has kind
of placed his pieces optimally for this
attack these bishops are bearing down on
the king this rook ready to swing into
action this rook ready to back it up but
how do you break down the black king's
castle structure what about rook e5 well
rooks are worth more than bishops so if
at all possible you don't really want to
complicate things with an exchange
sacrifice even if it's good White has an
advantage for nothing here so why
instead go for Bishop position where you
might still have the advantage but your
opponent has something for it right you
don't want to give them that kind of
hope okay everybody agrees of course
though the move is h4 and after h5 we
are going for the throat Queen d8 is
what kappa blanka tried trying to really
reroute now note that the move c5 might
even be a better try here for for
capital Blanca in fact trying
desperately to free this Bishop but of
course it's it's just going to be a
really tough position here with moves
like before even coming on the board and
we're going to get more of the same but
perhaps you know a little bit better in
this variation with this Bishop having
some breathing room instead though just
Queen d8 now after h5 the light squares
are falling apart
Queen g5 is blacks try to reroute this
Queen to help defend some squares but
now Bishop takes g7 King takes g7 and
rookie five and white is just invading
Queen e7 rook de 1 now getting the final
rook into the action rook over to g8
cleaning c1 is Lasker's choice aiming
for these dark squares rook 88 and now
the second rook is lifted up and goes to
some nasty squares Bishop c8 Rick h3
King f8 this move is check rook g7 and
now we break through on the h-file
Bishop takes g6 is the sacrifice that
does it for Lasker of course if you
capture this guy
this move is check you come to f7 then
Rick f3 in Africa g8 then rook f3
anyways and nowhere to go with this King
to keep this rook safe so Bishop takes
g6 is nice Queen f6 now and rook over to
g5 just defends this Bishop and it's
kind of the meanest way to play King up
to e7
but now rook f3 and with all the pieces
falling
coming into the attack kappa blanka
chose to simply sacrifice the Queen here
and Rick takes f3 or G takes f 3 rook
over g8 King F 1 we see takes takes and
takes Queen h2 and then somehow in this
endgame there's a little bit of
shuffling but this one is just very very
clearly a dead win for white White has
an extra pawn and an extra Queen which
always helps
so King d7 Queen f4 we see f6 now see
for a 6 we see Queen h4 there was a
check a check and white picks up this
pawn now Rick at 5 this move is check
King e2 Queen H a check Queen inch to
check Queen d6 or catch v King III rook
f5 King e4 or kitc 5 check check and we
triangulate for some reason we got five
and we triangulate again but at the end
of the day
kappa blanka just gesture science and
white wins this game okay so why did
kappa blanka resign well it seems like
he was holding this fortress here but
white is is going to eventually just be
able to break through I mean I mean
white white is up a queen for example if
you continue passing well it's quite
difficult to consume passing but okay
King c7 and you can start pushing these
pawns on the Queen side I think I didn't
analyze this endgame too in-depth so
forgive me if I get some things wrong
but the point of this game that I really
wanted to show is Lasker's positional
prowess and how he played against this
LightSquared Bishop stuck on the c8
square and managed to make kappa blanka
just look a little bit foolish not ever
getting to not ever getting in this
bishop into the game was kappa blanka at
his prime in this game how old was he
yeah this game was played in 1935
forgive me once again I don't know my my
kappa blanka history I feel like this
was when he was playing some pretty good
chess feel he was playing pretty good
chess in 1935 might be wrong kappa
blanka was 47 yes see look
Lasker still killing it in his old age
all right one last game for you guys
I've got a manual a skirt against two
rosh so lasker playing all of the
heavyweights in his heyday and making
them all look like fools
okay in this game of course Lasker
starts with E for this seems to be his
mo a five-night f3 knight c6 Bishop e5
a6 Bishop a4 Knight f6
castles Bishop e7 rook over to e1
defending upon b5 now Bishop b3 d6 c3
Knight a5 is blacks choice and this is
the
a pretty common line in the ROI slightly
more common is like castles first or
something I'm not a royal apes' player
but I think 95 is is pretty common
Bishop C 2 and now C 5 and this is the
the classic maneuver for black to gain a
little bit more central control free his
pieces a little bit by taking some Queen
side space and playing against this
Bishop on on b3 here
and so that's exactly what is done in
this game now white wasted no time
Alaska breaks in the center immediately
with d4 Queen c7 is black's choice
getting this Queen on the C file and
supporting the center Knight bd2 knight
c6 it's all kind of classic roy stuff
even if the move order is a little bit
funny here knight back to c6 is in fact
not really the most common idea though I
should say leaving this knight on a 5
and does control some nice squares here
on the on the Queen side but 96 it's
just trying to put a little bit more
pressure on this Center h3 was White's
choice in this game and black went ahead
and got castled now there are a variety
of moves that white can play here d5 is
the most common try for white you can
also open things up a bit with D takes
e5 but Alaska plays the move Knight f1
keeping the tension in the center now
with this Knight moving away from the
center tirage takes the opportunity to
open the center with C takes D for C
text e4 Knight takes Knight takes he
takes and here Lasker deviates from a
previous game he had against rush in the
previous game I think he played Knight
g3 I have his notes from chess games
with me in this game though he tried
Bishop g5 and so Bishop g5 gets this
Bishop into the game it is eyeing this
knight on f6 and now it gives this rook
some access to the C file where the
black queen assists h6 is Black's idea
forcing this bishop away bishop h4 Queen
b6 now
and now I'll let you try and find whites
next turn our White's next move here
it's pretty common actually for
positions that I've seen in this type of
structure white will quite often in the
roid Lopez positions where he takes d4
ends up being played will have this pawn
sitting on e4 and this is not the square
it wants to be on so try and find a way
for Lasker to open up some lines in a
very clever very creative way
yes so everybody sees the big idea in
one form or another in my opinion it's
better not to play e5 immediately if you
play e5 immediately you kind of just tip
your hand here black can capture and I
mean Queen d3 well no there's there's
efore so you would of course have to
take this back I think a lot better is
to first play this move Queen d3 and now
it's kind of the the case of the threat
being stronger than than the execution
here so Queen d3 threatens to first take
off this Knight and then play e5 when
white would in fact just be winning a
piece and now black unfortunately
couldn't really find the best way to
deal with this
maybe rook e8 was actually potentially
playable with the idea being with the
rook off of e8 the King now does have a
flight Square and so black could just
take on e5
instead though trashed red more direct
g5 removing the threat of Bishop takes
f6 which would remove this defender but
now g5 is just a little bit too
weakening on the black Kings side Bishop
g3 has played Bishop e6 and now just the
simple move from lasker rook a d1 he
doesn't get caught up with the immediate
tactics of a 5 he just attacks this pawn
which cannot be defended gets his rook
into the game also notably after the
move rack FC 8 which was played in the
game we can drop this Bishop quite
comfortably back to b1 and we are not
leaving our route out of the game very
very principled chest by Lasker 97 comes
on the board and now of course is the
time the move Bishop c4 was perhaps a
better try Queen takes d4 it would of
course be regaining the pawn and white
would have a lot of pressure on d6 in a
great position but even the move Queen
f3 is going to be quite awkward for
black to deal with the threat of a 5 is
still coming
with Bishop takes and these bishops just
uh you know these bishops being lasers
lasering the black King site that's the
verb I'm gonna use best when I come up
with but okay
instead of Bishop c4 97 is just not
going to be enough
'if I've comes on the board now you have
to stop queen h7 so night of fate has
played Queen f3 was White's choice no
after d5 Queen up to h5 and these things
are just falling apart
so King up to g7 and now let's see if
you guys can find the knock out blow the
knockout blow
once again the knockout blow for Lasker
here how do you break down your
opponent's defenses you've gotten your
pieces into great positions which is
really the part of the game where Alaska
gets the edge but now these knockout
blows are also fantastic
so yeah everybody has pretty similar
ideas here you want to break down this
pawn on g5 in this case I don't think h4
is the way to do it with h4 maybe the
threatened just isn't quite severe
enough you you're threatening to to take
on g5 but it's it's not really all you
want it to be you know this this H pawn
leaving doesn't actually help quite all
that much as Black is the one who's
ready to come to the H file so the idea
is in fact f4 the idea is not so much to
take this pawn on g5 instead the threat
is going to be for example just any move
thread is going to be f5 here and now f5
f6 is going to be the devastating win
and that white needs so instead of
simply allowing this to happen
thrush tries to move f5 but this move is
is not going to be enough
he takes f6 comes on the board Bishop
takes f6 f takes g5 now H takes g5 and
Bishop e5 is just devastating taking
away the last defender of this G pawn in
front of the king d3 is check so king h1
and now after 96 Lasker just takes this
free pawn on g5 in the game is over
Bishop f7 night up to g3 Bishop takes d5
rook takes e5 rook over to h8 Bishop
takes d3 rook a7 Rick de1 King up to 8
we see takes takes Queen e3 not trading
the Queen's here of course that would be
ridiculous this would be an absurd move
even if the endgame is winning so Queen
e3 instead Rick c7 9 f5 and these
threats are just too much
Queen c6 Queen g5 and this is where
black chose to resign in the game so
another huge win by Lasker here over his
rivals of the day hopefully this game or
this lecture gives you some insight into
the kind of player Lasker was I think he
was
one of the first kind of complete chess
players right I mean you had a players
like steinitz who were very
materialistic they would like grab stuff
and just hold on forever and ever and
ever you had other players who were very
good tactician
players who were great at attacking
players who were great and you know
defending maybe like trot like sorry
Steinitz but Lasker was the whole
package he out plays kappa blanka in
positional chess he out calculates
marshall in attacking chess and it
combines the two so well to play these
perfect complete games where you know
start-to-finish Lasker's in control and
Lasker is in dominating so hopefully you
guys have grown to appreciate these
games of Lasker I liked them quite a bit
with that in mind that does it for
tonight's lecture on the road to 2000 if
you're watching live be sure to stay
tuned on the YouTube channel we will be
having the endgame class coming right up
after this if you're watching the video
thank you
that is all my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]